first up teleporting here he is a former
Harvard instructor of risk communication
and risk psychology and author of how
risky is it really can you guess why we
booked him David row Pete okay thank you
so much David how are you I'm fine yes
you are that I'm not there so that I
could not shake hands with you in person
but you know what I want to tell people
you were perfectly fine with getting on
the plane we said you know what we've
done to satellite before maybe this is a
good time to do it to set an example but
tell me first about that like you're the
guy this is why I wanted to have you on
tonight because the title of your book
is so perfect how risky is it getting on
a plane how risky is it the air doesn't
transport this stuff so it's just
surfaces that you touch and you touch
them in the airports so the flying out
isn't any different than that but we
hear about oh people aren't flying and
that feeds our kind of emotional
relationship to risk that's it's a
perfect example of what this whole
conversation I hope will be about you
said perfectly in your monologue quote
you we don't do smart stuff in this
country when there's a risk around we
don't do smart stuff we don't use the
prefrontal cortex the reasoning part of
our code touch your head yeah
by the way I've been introduced a lot of
times this is the first time there was a
reference to oral sex in the Oval Office
and the introduction lead-in to me thank
you
no no the series the serious point is in
coronavirus is a great teaching moment
for this we are hardwired to use our
emotions more than reason all the time
but especially when it comes to keeping
ourselves safe so what happens is we get
one or two or three quick facts and we
have to do this quick in case the thread
is like right there right and then we
run them through a lot of subconscious
emotional filters our personal
circumstances are we healthy are we old
our age our gender all those things and
a set of instincts that we all share
that make some risks feel scarier and
some risks feel less scariest so imagine
like a bunch of stained-glass windows
right so we're here we have a few facts
we're looking through all this dark
color right and from that we're supposed
to be objective on the other side with
statistics and evidence it's not how we
do it we end up as a result being more
afraid than we need to like now or
sometimes less afraid then we should be
like with influenza but doc you know the
stained glass windows a better analogy
because a lot of people look at that and
think that's the answer and they pray
and they pray that's for exactly a
second they pray a lot of people suggest
about religion for exactly this
psychology so one of the things that
coronavirus is scary about is that it's
new everybody says yeah it's new it's
scary why is that scary new as a new
cellphone is not scary new is not
knowing and not knowing means we don't
know what we need to know to protect
ourselves I'm not seeing isn't that it
we don't know about it and we can't
quite see it and we can't quite control
our own safety because we don't know how
to keep ourselves safe no talk about
seeing it's like driving down the road
if you can get going at any speed in Los
Angeles and your eyes are closed that's
scary right so we turn in fact to
religion and many other things masks
toilet paper they're all the same
for a sense of control when we don't
have personal control we look
port in other ways wait masks and toilet
paper are the same yeah and sorry Chad I
don't live with you don't love right now
but now you get it right now whenever I
hear about this kind of stuff I always
think of my little dog Chico because you
know he loves to eat the end of my
cereal in the bowl and when I put it
down but if I leave the spoon in the
bowl that is a risk he will not take he
loves that cereal but he will not go
near the bowl if there's a [ __ ] spoon
in it yet when I pull in the driveway he
runs right in front of the car two words
people don't fight or not good at
assessing risk that's your right
yeah well dogs I've had several dogs
they're awesome they're great teachers
about this because they're totally in
the moment they're taking their cues
from absolutely only the evidence in
front of them not yesterday not tomorrow
not all these characteristics that make
risk feel like Tyree or less like
control well yeah okay so so I you know
the panic I feel is making things worse
than the actual disease what I see you
gesturing yeah you know that's
absolutely spot-on two things first of
all panic is when the zombies are
attacking us or the wrong person gets
elected right
panic is society run amok we're gonna
panicking when we buy toilet paper it
may look silly we're not doing smart
things like you said but we're looking
for a sense of control and that's
instinctive precaution it doesn't match
the facts that's what I'm saying this
whole conversation is our fears are what
we're going on not just the evidence
alone but we're not panic panicking
excuse me but what we are do when doing
when we overreact is sometimes we're
creating other risks so let me be very
specific here there are people who are
more worried about this than they need
to be and that worry suppresses their
immune system and makes them more
vulnerable to getting the thing they're
worried about yep yeah if you lose sleep
if you have stress those are terrible
factors for your immune system yeah
exactly you know the only analogy I
could think about this time
is when aids hit which is not exactly
analogous but people were panicked and I
do remember a period when we didn't know
much about it and people thought they
were saying maybe it could go airborne
and that made people freaked out exactly
it was the not knowing you said it again
and the not knowing leaves us feeling
like I don't know how to protect myself
I was putting the mic on for this and it
was coming the guy in the in the studio
that when I was a reporter in Boston in
the 80s I worked for a union and they
wouldn't let me touch any of the gear
until it was time to mic up an AIDS
patient and they were scared so I did to
my king up because I wasn't when you
don't know what you need to know to
protect yourself you're more afraid but
if I made a broad in a conversation
that's only one of these several
characteristics that make us more or
less afraid we're more afraid of
man-made risks than natural risks we're
more afraid of risk that's now than
later
that's climate change that's why we're
not as afraid as we should Road Lima
change right this language of risk
perception psychology that I wrote about
and that we're talking about this is
just one example so I feel like our
general posture as a nation has become
one of fragile people if we were a
hearty er people who weren't afraid of
everything to begin with you know kids
can't walk to school on their own like
they did when I was a kid kids cannot be
left alone that that's a free-range
child that's verboten these days I feel
like we would be in a better place to
handle this because we're already so
anxious about stuff that we shouldn't be
anxious about don't you think that's a
part of it it is a part of it and it's
cold in the scientific literature the
social amplification of risk which
basically means that how we hear about
things which aren't always perfectly
factual and accurate and they go through
our feelings lead us to perceive that
risk in ways where we do other things
that are bad to us like teaching our
kids that it's a scary world with this
with drills in school that you're going
to be shot the statistical risk of which
is infinitesimal the messages that we're
sending each other that crime is bad
here and oh my god the sky is falling
every which way like coronaviruses now
make no mistake the risk is real and
serious and we should acknowledge that
feeds a general sense of what george
gerbner at the university of
pennsylvania's passed away used to call
the mean world syndrome if all we hear
about is that the sky is falling we walk
around ducking what did he pass away
from being old not a not important duck
not important let me ask you one last
question
yeah I brought this up last week and I
hope it's somewhat true which is that I
feel like they they being mean the
authorities so we don't know quite
exactly who's doing the talking but the
information we get tend to when there's
a crisis lurching they they tend just
tell us it's gonna be worse so that when
it's not as bad we go oh good that
wasn't as bad it's it's better to be
pleasantly surprised
you know the examples I gave were y2k
was going to be horrible at the turn of
the century and then there was the BP
oil spill which was going to be horrible
and the fires of Kuwait remember after
the Gulf War Saddam Hussein lit all the
oil wells on fire in Kuwait and that was
going to be years in the making and it
was eight months before they put it out
do you think that's the same thing here
they're telling us it's going to be
worse so that when it's not as bad we're
pleasantly surprised it's part of it but
they're two sides of it so let me start
on the other side first and get back to
your side a lot of people in power don't
like the fact that people are more
afraid than they need to be and are what
they call you call panicking why in
toilet-paper right they try to control
that with the don't panic message God
how many times have we heard that from
all the people at the very top well you
don't hear it from the reasonable people
at the CDC you don't hear it from the
reasonable people at the WTO they
understand the importance of respecting
our feelings not trying to control them
and telling people hey you should feel
like I want you to feel which sounds
like I want you to feel like that so you
can go buy stocks and be happy and I
won't take any grief for this it's
disrespectful to tell people how they
feel the hell people don't do that but
what they do is what you said
there's worse coming and there is that's
a way to put things in perspective now
when they get worse so they won't freak
us out even more let's talk about this
is like the normal flu that's not
comparing the two diseases they're
different but it is a way of saying
let's put in perspective that we've
lived through something like this before
so it doesn't feel as new which makes it
feel scarier okay
thank you you put a lot in perspective I
appreciate that you up touching your
head thank you David and let's meet our
panel
you